[Musik]
hallo hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute
käsekuchen aus dem glas und zwar nobel-
kalsow sind eigentlich die perfekten
komponenten käsekuchen liebe dich über
alles das ist aus den klassen immer gut
und norway gerade im sommer ist perfekt
das rezept ist super unkompliziert und
ich starte jetzt auch direkt mit unserer
creme habe ich dafür reichen die
deutschen anhänger
das war übrigens doppel ram frischkäse
genau nimmt er auf jeden fall doppel ram
frischkäse natürlich könnt ihr bei
dieser kosten darf auch auf fettarme
variante zurückgreifen
aber ich mag ihn ganz gerne und den süße
ich jetzt mit etwas puderzucker alle
ganz genauen mengenangaben findet ihr in
der infobox oso und da gebe ich jetzt
noch quark mit dazu ich gebe heute mag
es richtig fertig ich habe hier den
40-prozentigen genommen ihr könnt auch
den 20-prozentigen oder den magerquark
nehmen das ist gar kein thema könnte
komplett austauschen so dass frühere ich
jetzt aber erst mal miteinander bundes
unterstützt
[Musik]
so das habe ich jetzt 30 sekunden
miteinander verrührt er braucht auch
keine maschine schneebesen reicht
vollkommen
und jetzt kommen die zwei super
komponenten vanille extrakt und
zitronenschalen abrief ich brauche kein
zitronensaft wir brauchen wirklich nur
den abrieb daher unbedingt eine bio
zitrone nehmen damit wir eben nicht die
ganzen spritzer stoffe die da drin sind
diese ganzen gespritzten sachen die
später nicht in der creme haben
[Musik]
schaut euch das mal an schaut euch mal
diese vanille pünktchen an und die creme
ist jetzt auch schon fertig
so jetzt habe ich mir die creme in
meinen spritzbeutel mit großer loch
telefon eingeführt sei es einfacher
jetzt in die schmalen gläsern zu kommen
und ich mache es jetzt so ist ein
bisschen außer puste weil wir gerade
fliege gejagt haben
ich mache es jetzt so ich nehme hier zum
biscuits ihr könntet auch war wisse
diese eier plätzchen nehmen oder löffel
diskret oder allgemein kekse die
mögliche oder oder oder oder
und ich mache es jetzt so kurios auch
eine gute idee dann würde ich sie aber
nicht jetzt hier eintunken weil ich
denke die kekse jetzt in die flüssigkeit
von meinen dosen mandarin wie ich hier
also ich hab die flüssigkeit aufgefangen
und die dosen mandarin brauchen wir auch
gleich gibt einfach ein bisschen
geschmack genau und so verschwinden halt
auch nicht eine sekunde reintun jetzt
gebe ich hier das glas rein das ist dann
quasi unser boden
[Musik]
als nutzer hälfte gefüllt
genau mandarinen und jetzt noch mal so
[Musik]
und jetzt noch hier so ein mini soft
cache einfach hier an die seite und
deswegen für aus dem cocktail finde ich
etwas witziges erzählen wie viele mini
soft facts sind in so einer packung
chips jetzt in die kommentare genau
jetzt
wir haben dem stück lust und den 46
stimmt nur noch übrig wenn man einfach
alle aufgefuttert gut hast ja nur zweite
packung geholt haben so wirklich ob ich
die listen also ich habe eine ganze
packung alleine weg kann aber haben sich
voll angefixt der nach starter schlimm
gut dass ich den zeit habe ich schon
immer eine backup packung weil ich weiß
wie süßes im haus haben dann geht das
eigentlich
[Musik]
okay ihr lieben das war es auch schon
mit dem rezept das ging jetzt echt
ruckzuck und das sieht mega mega
festlich aus acht stück ganz genau acht
stücke könnten auch die mengen jetzt
halbieren wenn ihr nur 4 haben möchte
aber es stellt das rechtlich nicht
bindend ist ja auch so also ich sag mal
wissen wie viel rauskommt und ich
probiere meint man müsste jetzt
irgendwie alles probleme und nicht der
keks und hier aber ich gehe einfach mal
hier so rein
wir machen sehr frisch schmeckt echt so
nach neuwerk cheesecake weiß es ja auch
frischkäse es ist vanille es ist
zitronenscheibe wir haben sowohl auch
probieren kein problem auch mal vor der
kamera
ok dann auf instagram und das finden wir
die szenen ein und ihr müsst doch
instagram folgen wir nicht schon längst
okay das ist ein deal alles klar
so also ich finds richtig geil ich habe
das nie viel öfter machen vor allem wenn
besuch kommt spontan und euch jetzt ganz
viel freude beim nachmachen
schreibt mir auch gerne einen kommentar
ich weiß was ich auf merzen liegt hier
unten dann schreiben wir miteinander
dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
mal hier auf dieses kit chinchillas und
hab ich nicht richtig gemacht
[Musik]